il a le courage de venir comme à chaque
fois il faut noter quand même c'est
Pierre jean-charlançon que tu es avec
nous bonjour Mon Chéri alors la
Pierre-Jean j'avoue que je me perds
écoute c'est très simple et très juste
un mot quand même je perds parce que une
fois tu as reçu ici on t'a dit mais
tiens tu fais une photo Dieudonné il a
pas polémique tu me dis ah oui mais
j'étais à côté j'ai fait une photo j'ai
pas vu un jour tu tiens tu as insulté
une vieille dame qu'on aime beaucoup les
autres tu as dit pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
est pas encore morte alors oui c'était
un jeu de mots c'était maladroit mais
bon pourquoi pas après tu es au premier
rang du Gala de Zemmour on aime on
n'aime pas mais tu sais que c'est
provocateur à nouveau et à chaque fois
que tu arrives je suis arrivé il y avait
une place
on m'a invité je suis allé voir ce que
c'était bon il y a chaque fois il y a un
truc mais je me dis ce type est
intelligent il va s'en sortir là pour
donner une dernière info je tourne
Pierre-Jean Chalençon pour un
documentaire qu'on fait sur Paris
merci la chaîne me dit on met pierre
genre dedans mais je te préviens un
dérapage vous coupez tout ça veut dire
retourner en salle de montage reprendre
un monteur et tu perds 3000 balles juste
on arrivera pas tu as dit pas
intelligent j'arrive à mon bureau et je
vois Pierre-Jean Chalençon souhaite bon
anniversaire à Poutine et beaucoup de
3000 balles alors là j'aimerais quand
même comprendre qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui t'est passé là par la tête parce que
là vraiment même moi ça m'a pas fait
rire en fait
Poutine oui mais c'est jamais alors je
souhaite l'anniversaire aux gens que je
connais j'ai jamais souhaité
l'anniversaire à Monsieur Poutine je
connais pas ce monsieur par contre
je t'explique j'étais au festival de
Dinan avec justement Alain Fabien nous
montre sur les marches et je reçois sur
Tik Tok cette vidéo et j'ai trouvé cette
vidéo tellement drôle tellement décalée
parce que moi j'en ai rien à branlé de
ce type là mais ça m'a ça m'a fait rire
et judiciaire je l'arbre balancé tout
voilà j'ai honnêtement fait ça mais
comment peut-on attendez comment peut-on
moi m'imaginer être un ami de ce type là
ou de ses idées je suis le seul people
en tout cas le seul organisateur
d'événementiel qui a organisé fin juin
une soirée avec plus de 400 Ukraine mais
les gens le savent ça
je ne pleurerai pas et j'ai moi-même
fait même une vente aux enchères que
j'ai
personnellement où j'ai récupéré plus de
10000 euros et il y avait même mis sur
graines et là en ce moment d'ailleurs
nous sommes en train d'organiser d'une
nouvelle soirée pour l'Ukraine pour
justement aider à bien
c'est comme si demain moi je déguise
comme si moi je m'étais bon anniversaire
Hitler avec une vidéo j'en parlerai plus
du jour moi si les gens savaient ma mère
était allemande j'ai un beau-frère qui
habitait dans le Nord
je suis français je suis parisien
charité bien ordonné commence par
soi-même moi ce type là il est pas du
tout sympathique pourquoi tu souhaites
chaque jour j'ai simplement reposé une
vidéo
j'ai jamais fait plutôt
c'était tellement drôle c'est pour se
[ __ ] de sa gueule
ma chérie maintenant
je comprends que ce soit une blague
façon de Charlie Hebdo tel que tu le dis
là sauf que ça ne se comprend
quand on fait une blague et qu'on a
besoin de l'expliquer c'est qu'elle est
pas drôle écoute moi je pensais que
c'était drôle on s'amusait
ça voilà c'est tout je me suis expliqué
lundi mardi matin avec Guillaume Genton
je lui ai expliqué il m'a dit ben bien
sûr bon après sur le coup bon mais moi
ce type là j'ai aucun intérêt surtout
quand je souhaite un anniversaire je le
souhaite des gens normaux mardi soir
j'étais au Lutetia j'ai rencontré
Monsieur Gérard Darmanin c'était son
anniversaire je lui ai serré la main je
lui ai souhaité un joyeux anniversaire
voilà c'est tout c'est pas pour ça que
je partage les idées de Monsieur
Darmanin mais je suis élégant et poli
mais je dis place et politesse que je
n'ai jamais souhaité l'anniversaire
c'est pas que c'est un défenseur mais
c'est c'est la vérité c'est l'humour de
la communication aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
prête aux images les messages qu'on veut
entendre sauf que ça à pied birthday
toteen ça a été fait quand le pouls
Crimée était bombardé que c'était pile
ou mon anniversaire et que c'était comme
une sorte de foutage de gueule bon
anniversaire Poutine elle vient de
détruire ton pont et c'est pris comme un
hommage à Poutine alors que c'était une
vidéo sarcastique
qui s'adressait sur France Télévision à
des gens voilà qui les regarde tu sens
un peu plus âgés donc il y a pas 53
explications
faut penser à des trucs historiques
machin et tout on est quand même avec
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup mais qui a
chanté passe-moi ton QR code
différents
Poutine avec le pont qui cramé ça a été
que des vidéos ça a des choses
sarcastiques
malheureusement j'en fais ce que tu dis
est vrai le problème c'est que c'est lui
qui l'a fait et donc c'est la même
personne qu'on a son neuvième dérapage
donc forcément la page facebook
aujourd'hui je te rappelle
que cette chose alors
on va en finir avec ça tout le monde
sait que j'ai pas une sympathie
médiatique pour qu'on se connaît pas
dans la vie privée
etc j'ai rien contre lui évidemment mais
à chaque fois je vous fais un moment
donné pour moi le truc de Poutine c'est
pratiquement le moins grave moi je
partage totalement la vie de Jean-Michel
contrairement à ce que tu dis je pense
que on oublie juste que cette vidéo a
été postée au moment où les ukrainien
ont tapé le pont et que c'était le jour
de sa gueule bien sûr un doigt et de
dire happy birthday
ça ça va vérifier maintenant que lui ait
trouvé ça plutôt rigolo et drôle etc
sans savoir les crimes de Poutine pareil
dans les gens qui ont suivi je peux
comprendre pour moi il y a plus grave il
y a bien plus grave que d'eau etc etc
les pardon mais les mensonges sur les
dîners etc pendant le confinement le
fait que tu as dit qu'il y avait des
ministres qui étaient venus alors que
c'était faux bon mais je n'ai pas dit ça
si tu l'as dit je te jure
sur cette histoire jamais de la vie mais
jamais tu as mis non non non
en tout cas j'ai pas été poursuivi j'ai
pas suivi si parce que j'ai pas été peu
importe la question
tu es associé avec des gens justement
donc un monsieur Gérard Darmanin pour
son anniversaire je suis en a rien à
voir
plutôt sulfureux parle même pas de la
partie restauration tu fais toujours
parler de toi dans le bad buzz alors que
tu as une personnalité il l'a rappelé
formidable que tu as fait des trucs
assez intéressant que tu es un passionné
de plein de trucs pour toi je vis soit
tu as besoin de défendre
toujours invité aujourd'hui mais
crois-moi dans un an ou deux ans mais tu
seras plus vite mais tu sais j'ai pas
besoin de venir à la télévision pour
exister
j'ai eu 20000 visiteurs ça a été un
carton j'ai eu le meilleur tout le monde
là je prépare j'ai énormément de choses
en Vendée j'organise pleine enfin j'ai
fait des expulsions avec Philippe de
ville il y a 20 ans sur Napoléon très
bien j'ai organisé aux États-Unis très
bien je gère le palais Vivienne qui est
un lieu magnifique
et j'ai envie de rigoler un petit peu je
suis avec fine donc parler que pour dire
des conneries il y a toujours des trucs
qui font que tu as 10 personnes plutôt
censées qui tombent dessus sniper qui
sont toujours à dire celui-là on va se
taper
on a pas besoin de c'est soit je peux
répondre Jean-Michel et Laurent parce
que vous dites que c'est de l'image
c'est pas grave et cetera je suis désolé
Pierre-Jean il a plus de 60000 followers
sur Instagram ils sont pas tous tous ces
followers ne sont pas tous aussi
cultivés les traits que lui ne suivent
pas l'actualité comme forcément comme
comme Laurent ou comme comme Jean-Michel
donc à un moment donné comment il
perçoivent ce message là quand il voit
ta vidéo c'est ça que tu faut
pas un truc aussi
j'ai
toujours au palais pour toi Napoléon
petite vannes parce que Laurent trouvé
que Pierre-Jean est un peu à
transpiration adore le parfum de
Napoléon donc je n'ai toujours pour toi
ce que je voulais faire par là c'est que
et tu le sais Laurent il y a en
t'apporter à n'importe quelle école de
marketing et il y a les cris et il y a
l'oral si je prends le téléphone et que
je dis ouais le haut tu es un peu con tu
vois là si je t'envoie à l'écrit on a
tous vécu avec un texto n'importe qui de
la prod quand Cyril Hanouna nous avons
un texto c'est tu vois tu es con pour un
là c'est trois mots il y a pas la
solution il y a rien donc les degrés
c'est très compliqué et lui souvent ben
tu dis un truc il poste quelque chose
quelque chose qui est tweeté ou qui est
écrit tout d'un coup c'est plus une
blague c'est une attention quoi c'est
pas la même chose du responsable en
réalité
j'aimerais la vie des autres tiens
Benoît par exemple moi Pierre-Jean je le
vois vraiment comme un enfant ne
serait-ce que personne sourire sa façon
de gesticuler je pense qu'il teste tout
le monde il est toujours il est en quête
d'amour de il a il a besoin des
projecteurs il a besoin de se faire
aimer du public je pense qu'il a
vraiment un mail un mal-être avec
lui-même je pense qu'il est toujours en
quête d'amour et c'est comme un enfant
qui a jamais grandi c'est même pas ce
qu'il fait vitesse un sale gosse
Pierre-Jean c'est un sale gosse
exactement
ta réponse et puis après Sophie qui va
t'insulter
une sorte de personnage de bébé
récemment on m'a mis dans une dans une
dans une BD sur la genèse de Napoléon et
c'est moi qui fait visiter aux enfants
voilà mais moi j'aime l'histoire j'aime
je suis un feel good et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont devenus ah
c'est méchant j'ai rencontré j'ai vu
deux trois jours Jean-Michel maire
Verdez pardon Gilles et il me dit tu
sais aujourd'hui il me dit je t'adore
mais tu sais aujourd'hui on peut plus on
peut plus rire et on peut plus rien de
rien du tout et toi tu es un mec qui
aime rire voilà et bah si vous voulez
fermer sa gueule
je rappelle c'est fait après Sophie
aieme faut quand même parce que tu avais
aussi bon alors tu avais clasher Line
Renaud ça j'avoue bon ça j'avoue alors
après tu as une très bonne humeur
c'est merveilleux mon petit Delormeau
décidé de me marier avec Jean-Michel
maire d'ailleurs je demande à tous les
Françaises et les Français de donner un
euro pour le petit de leurs mots pour
une nouvelle paire de chaussures
[Applaudissements]
mais c'était méchant et si elle a le
problème tu as tout pire Jean il est
drôle et il tient la phrase de trop la
connerie trop il avait souhaité sa mort
comment peut-on faire ça tu avais
soutenu jean-luclette c'est encore un
beau feu d'arme tu avais même plus un
coup de gueule après avoir appris qu'il
ait été placé en garde à vue alors ça
c'est là aussi c'est du ouais parce que
je l'adore Jean-Luc c'est vraiment un
truc des filles mais c'est un pote quoi
c'est un poteau ouais mais quand même
j'adore ces chansons moi c'est bon c'est
ma jeunesse
et pourquoi il est gentil j'adore cette
chanson il a été condamné par le passé
pour viol et tu dis j'adore ces chansons
où ça tourne plus
vous savez très bien ce que vous faites
vous adorez le bad buzz vous savez vous
le faites en votre année conscience et
je pense que c'est volontairement voilà
voilà ça c'est 10 Sophie je suis
absolument d'accord avec Ayem c'est
l'analyse que j'ai je connais pas
Pierre-Jean mais
de ce que je crois que je crois entendre
de ce que je crois entendre de lui c'est
vrai que vous avez une incroyable
culture vous avez un patrimoine voilà
vous défendez des choses assez nobles et
c'est gentil j'arrive pas à croire que
intellectuellement un moment donné ça se
connecte plus j'ai envie de me marrer je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui la vie est très
compliqué
attendez vous êtes feel good moi aussi
je suis très feel good mais il y a un
moment donné vous pouvez pas communiquer
de cette façon là tout le temps en fait
parce que vous pouvez faire un dérapage
mais quand on sait
à chaque fois en fait vous les voulez
cumuler on va dire donc on se finit par
se demander si finalement est-ce que dit
ayem est assez juste est-ce que vous
n'avez pas finalement comme marketing de
parler de vous de cette façon là je
pense que les gens me mettent sur
étonnamment c'est quand même très
étonnant ça fait 2 ans et demi que j'ai
terminé j'ai arrêté à faire conclure je
viens de temps à autre te voir et bien
sûr mais j'ai jamais été aussi apprécié
et populaire auprès des Français des
Belges etc alors un dernier mot toujours
ne changez rien ne change rien je ne
change rien
de ce soir dans le documentaire sur
Paris
magnifique
est-ce que tu regrettes est-ce que tu
regrettes par exemple depuis
franchement ils ont perdu un million de
vie de téléspectateurs
à une catastrophe